[Music]
bts's j-hope and becky g finally dropped
their long-awaited collab and it's
absolute fire
oh yeah and did I mention they blessed
us with the music video - what a day to
be alive anyway the track is called
chicken noodle soup duh and is a spin on
the classic 2006 track by DJ Webb star
and a young B chicken with some church
of chicken and chicken yeah you remember
those moves
well j-hope and Becky G threw it back
with the choreography and I am so here
for it okay but seriously guys can we
just take a minute to talk about J hopes
dance moves
like damn shortly after the release of
the video j-hope kicked off the chicken
noodle soup challenge posting this video
of himself performing the arm flapping
routine of course that went viral fast
AF with fans sharing their moves with
hashtag CNS challenge
[Music]
Jaeho and becky g first met in May at
the 2019 Billboard Music Awards when
they hung out backstage
Becky shared this pic with the boys of
BTS on Twitter writing BTS wanted me to
come down to their dressing room to hang
out like what is life there so nice
hashtag BTS army then in August she
posted a video on her Instagram story
that showed her on the set of a music
video with some Korean snacks now j-hope
was in LA at the time so naturally fans
began speculating that a collab could be
in the works just days before the song
dropped Becky G cryptically tweeted so
hashtag Becky has another secret
shortly after bts's account responded
and you better believe the fans lost
their damn minds and if that weren't
confirmation enough Becky then tweeted
these selfies with j-hope writing
chicken noodle soup anyone
[Music]
well I don't know about you guys but
I'll definitely be singing about chicken
noodle soup all day long of course you
can count on Ichi to keep you in the
know about all things BTS so make sure
to keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens chicken noodle
soup chicken noodle soup with a soda on
the side chicken
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]